hey man what's going on oh yeah I'm
[ __ ] freckled [ __ ]
it's the Thursday afternoon just before
Friday and Monday and moanin podcast
just checking in on you
Oh Billy's burning it at [ __ ] both
ends doo doo doo doo doo doo doo you
know I woke up this morning by duble do
poop and I went to the gym did some that
pull-downs and I had cuz I got it out of
the way I was going back and forth with
somebody this morning an East Coast
friend of mine who hadn't talked to in a
while how you enjoy being a dad and blah
blah blah blah blah and then she gets me
up with the whole hey I'm turning 50
this year I am not happy about I said
yeah I turned 50 last year she goes how
was turning 50 for you you know she goes
you're a guy you probably don't care
it's much harder for a woman especially
with our careers oh did I have fun with
that you know I just wrote back jesus
[ __ ] christ you know what I mean
white women complaining is one of the
funniest fits like you got a [ __ ]
house and a beautiful family what is the
[ __ ] prince so much harder for me
you're gonna outlive me by six to eight
years so me turn in 50s like me turning
like 56 57 58 you know you're made
complaining you know you never hear me
complain on this podcast this is nothing
but positivity rainbows and [ __ ]
unicorns yeah I love that [ __ ] it's
harder for it's harder for women to go
to the gym it's harder for us to lose
weight well then [ __ ] work harder you
know everybody's different oh is that
where it's hard you know was you know
it's harder for me trying to get some
woman to pay the cover charge and buy me
drinks you know it's harder for me to
divorce court
outliving you I mean it balances out
ladies getting child support yeah that's
harder for me cuz I'll be the one paying
it then all of a sudden it cost nine
hundred grand a month to raise a [ __ ]
two you're all right
I just don't understand the constant
complaining by white women okay you're
white
you live in America shut up okay wait to
the other problems is solved and then
we'll get to you you're at the meat
counter your number isn't up yet wait
your turn
do you know much hard it's so much
easier for you to go to jail it's not
easier men's lives are harder because we
have to live with you guys man I want to
become friends with a lesbian couple and
I want to like be friends with like the
chick in the relationship that's got a
handle more the dude [ __ ] you know cuz
you know opposites attract and I would
think even like in the lesbian community
there's gonna be somebody you know who's
out there swinging the axe getting the
[ __ ] fire wood while the other ones
in there making the muffins that's the
lesbian I want to talk to right into my
podcast please you know I want to know
if those lesbians on average die sooner
then then the the dainty lesbian you
know the lesbian who's got to go out on
the [ __ ] roof and adjust the [ __ ]
directv satellite [ __ ] thing in the
middle of the [ __ ] rain that's how I
wanna that's who I want to hear from
that's the study I would be doing
anyways oh geez I'm coming in hot
I'm coming in hot I'm wearing my old man
that I that I've got when I was over
there in Ireland you know and I'll tell
you it was so much harder for women to
find sweaters you know to be judged
anyway speaking of which I'm in the
middle of an acting gig right now and I
am having the time of my life I'm having
so much fun in this acting gig it's
actually scaring me because most of the
time comedians the entire time you're on
the acting gig you being like you know I
could have [ __ ] made you know twice
as much money in one hour that I have
that I'm gonna on this entire [ __ ]
shoot you know why am I still here
that's what you usually think it but
I've cracked the code I know how to do
it now what I do is is when I go on to
set I don't bring my phone and I don't
bring a watch and then it's like I
walked into a casino I don't know if
it's day I don't know if it's night I
just
I can do my [ __ ] I do it you know as
well as I can I listen to the director
whatever and then in between takes I sit
down and just conserve my [ __ ] energy
and that's all I do not looking at
anything I just sit there like [ __ ]
private Pyle when he's sitting on that
commode in Full Metal Jacket and then
all of a sudden after I feel like I've
been there two hours all of a sudden
okay well breaking for lunch I'm like oh
okay and then I go outside into the Sun
you know I get a salad with the protein
lady's salad with the protein heavy on
the salad protein no bigger than the
size of my pasty palm that's what I do
and then I just [ __ ] go back in and I
just do it all over again and I have no
[ __ ] idea what time it is and then
all of a sudden they just say you're
wrapped and I just act like a silly
jackass and trying to make jokes all day
long and I've been having the [ __ ]
time of my life having a great time so
anyways what am i acting on I'm not
allowed to tell it's a secret I'm acting
on General Hospital everybody okay I've
come back from the dead I a lot of
people don't know this I had a role on
that back in the 80s when I had a giant
orange [ __ ] afro and my character
died of cancer but now he's come back
from it you know his hair didn't grow
back yet but his beard did and that's
the jump off point to the character and
I am gonna go out on a limb and say this
is gonna be the most interesting
character since Heath Ledger's The Joker
okay I am the Heath Ledger Joker
character of General Hospital okay it's
an 87 episode arc that we shoot over the
course of one week I don't know what I'm
talking about anymore you know what you
know I'll tell you what I'm talking
about I'm talking about doing three
shows after this acting gig is over to
get myself ready to shoot my next
special I'm gonna be in Santa Barbara
Santa Barbara we're all the rich white
people in all
removed after they after they made money
in Hollywood alright then I'm going to
Pasadena
alright we're all the racist right wing
lunatics you know build the [ __ ] wall
of LA lift a lot of people don't realize
that a lot of people think everybody out
here is a liberal Larry that's not true
all you got to do is just go to Burbank
okay they're walking around they got
[ __ ] two-by-fours and pitchforks you
know I believe the kids say [ __ ] gets
real in Burbank and then I'm out in
Riverside okay
Riverside that part of America you know
that politicians don't bring up you know
the feminists don't bring up on their
attacking stand-up comedians acts they
forget what about all the poor people in
Riverside you know Riverside that just
sounds like a place we can dump a body
and you know what that's exactly what
happens if you ever kill anybody in Los
Angeles you have to know your next move
okay other than getting rid of your cell
phone is you drive the body to Riverside
okay as far as I know there is no River
there okay I don't know what I don't
know what it is but all I know there's
this enough gullies and there's just
enough dead people there already that
you can get lost in the herd with
dragging your dead body okay I will be
performing there Santa Barbara on
February 15th the day after the most
[ __ ] [ __ ] holiday there is that
you never hear a [ __ ] you know Peabody
a wife [ __ ] you see you hear what my
[ __ ] wife's asking me when did she
ask for this [ __ ] stupid designer
goddamn bag I swear to god it looked
like somebody dumped toothpaste all over
it you know like you know like when some
[ __ ] jackass partners up with some
high-end label to do their version of
the bag you know and then every [ __ ]
bored [ __ ] douche bag has to go get
the [ __ ] thing you know not say my
wife's bored I love her I just just I
looked at the bag I'm like you look at
that [ __ ] think that it's not gonna
what are you gonna do with that thing I
like it I think it's interesting it's
bold it's [ __ ] ugly as [ __ ]
I wish you guys could see this back
remember that stupid [ __ ] toothpaste
that came out that was like toothpaste
mouthwash and deodorant all at the same
time it looked like a [ __ ] rainbow
just imagine if you did that but it but
it was also like cloudy like milk and
you dumped that on a beautiful gorgeous
handmade [ __ ] bag that was perfectly
[ __ ] fine you know what it's art you
can't judge art yeah you can that stinks
okay it [ __ ] stinks you know that's
dead bags for like people who like you
know like jean-michel Basquiat you know
like the hacky artists that everybody
knows you know people just like to say
his guy's name just so they can make it
sound like they [ __ ] I'm just they
can speak French jean-michel Basquiat
you don't his [ __ ] stick figures I
mean I [ __ ] drew like that in the
first grade I had I can't believe how
much all those pictures I put on my
parent's refrigerator how much they'd be
worth nowadays I'm [ __ ] with you I
don't this one thing I don't know
anything about and if you don't believe
me just watch my act but I really don't
I don't know why I don't get Andy Warhol
just painting the tomato soup can
everything oh my God he's commented on
commercialism America all right
great comment how much is how much for a
[ __ ] can of soup and that canvas that
you [ __ ] put it on I'll give you that
amount of money for it anyways by the
way you know that guy got shot by a
woman I didn't know that and then she
did like [ __ ] three weeks in jail and
then got out and for the rest of his
[ __ ] life he's got to deal with this
crazy so-and-so running around out there
and then like 20 years later he kind of
died of complications from getting shot
by her you know but it's so much harder
anyways yeah I don't underst you know
the one guy I actually liked liked it
that I kind of understood and it's not
because I kind of look like the bald
version of him I didn't mind Van Gogh
oh really bill you didn't mind him did
you allow him in your artistic world I
didn't mean it like that the guy who
used the lines you know the vertical
lines any painted [ __ ] like that I like
that [ __ ] I don't know I like when
somebody paints somebody how they look
you know not when they stick their ear
in their forehead and it's like low man
like why do you think he did that you
know is that because he feels like
nobody can hear his thoughts
I mean is there layers to this no I just
think he [ __ ] knows how to draw an
ear and he stuck it on a forehead
he's probably dropping acid I don't know
or even all those canvases where it's
just it's it's nothing it's just it
looks like some toddler just [ __ ]
smeared it all over the place and it's
just like you know just like why you
know I just look at I'm like why did he
put that color over there
like why is that I saw Laura's one time
and some Metallica documentary and he
was selling this [ __ ] these [ __ ]
paintings he was getting all this money
for he was just going I just like that
over there is just like why did he put
that [ __ ] like I don't know Lars
I gotta go out on a limb I think you
could have done that to save yourself a
bunch of money but he turned around and
he sold it and he made even more [ __ ]
money and you combine that with the fact
that he gets his drum kits for free and
what you have is a very rich young man
um anyways how much time is that 12
minutes [ __ ] I got another [ __ ] 17
and a half to go jesus [ __ ] christ
you know some days this podcast you know
it just goes by quick and other times it
doesn't did anybody watch barstool
sports it the [ __ ] Super Bowl man how
[ __ ] fun was that they got into the
the the [ __ ] press conference and
Portnoy was asking I don't know any of
the names the Rams running back why he
took a D and I will cost him like four
grand on a bet and then what the NFL's
gonna [ __ ] kick them out it's like
that they're all about gambling they
have sports gambling now it's just like
you know it's their dirty little secret
you might as well just let fans ask
those questions right I thought it was
[ __ ] hilarious
and the only thing funnier than that was
afterwards when Portnoy did his
interview or when I was interviewing
thing and he was all [ __ ] amped up
saying like what were they gonna do it
him and he goes put the [ __ ] across on
me talking like he's [ __ ] Snake
Plissken what the [ __ ] I saw me I didn't
know he was like that Steven Seagal Dave
Portnoy I'm telling you man
you put him in a prison evidently
they're gonna take over but anyways I
thought that was really funny and then
he went on [ __ ] the new show there
with that [ __ ] weirdo looking guy
that guy he always goes on that guy's
show that guy who looks like you know he
that guy who killed his girlfriend
accidentally because they were having
rough sex
doesn't he look like one of those guys
and he was still wearing the costume
that you know God bless those guys it
[ __ ] barstool you know how boring is
the week between the AFC and NFC
championship game and the Super Bowl you
know put the motion of the bucket oh by
the way now the rough-and-ready
is coming up order that that's gonna be
in Atlanta and you know I heard I didn't
realize they said Portnoy was banned
from all NFL events I don't know how
many years ago but he's still allowed to
buy a ticket to the Super Bowl and go
right you know is he allowed to do that
are they gonna be sitting there do they
have this security all right this is
what Dave looks like without a fake
mustache hanging off his face and this
is what he looks like now with it on I
wonder how that works
I wonder these are the things that I
think about all right what are we up to
15 minutes just like that 15 minutes
just like that so anyways I went to the
gym this morning right as that woman was
texting me telling me how hard it was
for her to turn 50 you know I mean so
difficult I just can't imagine being a
white woman having to blow out all those
candles in your beautiful house I mean
God you know maybe you ought to think
about the children that put those
candles together in a sweatshop
they probably do that with their one arm
after they dug up some diamonds for you
I want that one alright anyways hey Bill
you have any Super Bowl predictions yes
I'm gonna age a hundred [ __ ] years
once again I am having a small select
group of people come over and I'm going
simple by the way anybody who's hosting
a Super Bowl party
all right don't let anybody talk you
into getting this all this [ __ ] food
all right nobody throws an event like my
lovely wife all right but the thing
about it is is afterwards you left with
a bunch of stuff and then you have to
eat it because you don't want it to go
bad and then like you know whatever you
enjoyed by the Emmy last time we had a
thing I think was for my daughter's
birthday I Salaria she turned to so we
had a two and under party right instead
of 21 and over you know two in under so
you had all these little kids there and
then like whatever say we had 10 kids
it's gonna be 20 parents there right
provided it's not a broken home so we
had to have all you know [ __ ] bagels
Sam like locks all of this [ __ ] dude I
was eatin [ __ ] salmon for like eight
[ __ ] days I mean it just afterwards
it's just like you know cuz oh that's
right so now I'm having my Super Bowl
party and Nia goes why don't you get a
caterer for it I said because I don't
want to be eatin [ __ ] hot dogs for
like the next 12 days so I just you know
I figured all right
the most anybody's gonna eat his two
burgers each the biggest I'm gonna make
the burgers probably a quarter pound
alright that's another thing too when
you make the homemade burgers don't make
them [ __ ] gigantic alright you can't
make them joke yet they think it's just
it becomes too much alright you gotta
make them like the same way Miller High
Life makes their beers somehow it's 12
ounces but it feels like [ __ ] four
and it just goes down easy that's what
you want to do because then they'll come
back and then they'll get the second one
you know what I mean yeah bill it's very
simple your theory is very simple so I'm
trying to like
have the least amount you know it's just
some chips and some beer and some
[ __ ] cigars and the great [ __ ]
thing is that this is a very very sexist
Super Bowl party in that it's men only
alright so they're not gonna give a [ __ ]
burgers and dogs they're in a little bit
of chips they bring the booze and I get
the cigars and then I'm good I'm out I'm
[ __ ] out all right worst thing I got
to do is I gotta wash [ __ ] you know
five to ten plates and this [ __ ] I used
on my flat top grill who gives a [ __ ]
and then I'm out and what I'm hoping is
is in the end that share Dalila Patriots
have won their sixth Superbowl
championship so I have six Super Bowl
championships zero AFL titles zero
afl-nfl championships and no NFL
championships
maybe it's because maybe this is what
III here's another theory have about why
they don't count NFL championships maybe
because the AFL at first was this
upstart league everybody laughed at the
league and then they got better and
better and better to the point the NFL
actually had to have a championship game
with them to show that they were the
superior league which they did for the
first two years and then the third year
they lost because they played Earl
morale instead of [ __ ] Johnny Unitas
some people say so they actually proved
that they were on par or at least good
enough to win one out of every three
championship games and at that point
they were like what are we doing here
why don't we just merge and we'll start
over again but having said all that it
was still called the NFL so maybe that's
why they do it but I think it's
unbelievably disrespectful to Sam Huff
Bobby Lane Frank Gifford all of these
Jim Brown all of these amazing Hall of
Famers to act as though like you know 10
bring up the championships within those
franchises that they played for that
have wreaked havoc on their bodies that
shortened their lives that you don't
even bring it up I just think it's
[ __ ] up bill we get it Jesus Christ
you've made the point how about you read
some advertising so we can laugh at your
inability to read out loud fine fine
I'll do it you don't think I'll [ __ ]
do it I'll [ __ ] do it I'll give my
wife so much [ __ ] about [ __ ]
Valentine's Day I'm like I'm not getting
you [ __ ] this year is your year what are
you gonna do for me huh she goes what do
you want for Valentine's Day I go I want
you to shut up I know I'm an [ __ ]
she laughed though she knows I'm a dick
you know I mean she knows what she
married she knows what she married she
now she married an [ __ ] like butcher
box butcher butcher box delivers 100%
grass-fed and grass-finished beef Alice
is great for your Super Bowl party
free-range organic chicken and deep in
achill of all murdered animals heritage
bread pork isn't bread BRE d BR EE D is
breed heritage breed pork is that what
it is have I been saying that wrong the
entire [ __ ] time don't you love when
you look up how to pronounce something
and then it's like it's not it's like
that white robot guy it's trying to
figure out how to say the name of this
person and then I got this that about
that uh alright pronunciation it is
breed I've been let me try oh it's a
lady oh it's about time all these robot
ladies have been suffering for so long
let's hear that again breed breed breed
so it is breed I thought Brad was BRE D
now that looks stupid
I'm the worst speller ever the
incredible quality of butcher box meats
starts with the commitment to raising
animals humanely and free of antibiotics
and hormones before they're assassinated
you know if I was actually if I was
working at a slaughterhouse I would like
I would build like a [ __ ] clock tower
and I'd have like the gun scope with the
hat turned around backwards I would just
do that
I'd go Oswald on him
cook with the peace peace of mind
knowing you are eating healthy and have
all the cows running around we got a
shooter you don't run it for cover high
quality meat each box comes with at
least 8 to 11 pounds of beef which is
enough for 24 individual size meals but
if you're a woman you're not allowed to
eat you can choose from five different
box types all beef beef and chicken beef
and pork mix box for the Liberals custom
box for the Conservatives just give me
whatever I'm picking out my own link
this is America you want my meat come
and get it you get to to the [ __ ]
neck
my favorite butcher block cut is
heritage breed pork
I think bread sounds better and because
I like toast announced announcing our
brand our new brand of protein wild you
can't believe I was gonna say dead
feminist foot yes run over at a rally so
announcing our new bread brand of
protein wild Alaskan salmon salmon
salmon butcher box sources they're pure
sustainably harvested salmon from
Bristol Bay Alaska unlike any salmon
you'll find in your local store
literally it's red color means that this
salmon is as fresh and nutrient rich as
it gets okay
and rather than you having to take a
trip up there to get it some other
person is going to catch it for you and
deliver it right to your goddamn door
the same person who caught it is gonna
show up and is all yellow [ __ ]
raincoat with that look in his face
gives the boat almost capsized during
the storm you know and you won't even be
able to look him in the eye cuz you're
not even nearly the man
but $20 off your first box and two
pounds of free salmon go to butcher box
comm slash burn enter / b you are r
that's butcher box.com / / and enter / b
you are r oh look who's left everybody
oh my goodness oh my goodness jolly
shave club Dollar Shave Club has
everything you need to look feel and
smell your best and you never have to go
to the store again you know it's funny
I'm all out of one wipe Charlies and I'm
too embarrassed to order more this guy's
[ __ ] that's because they deliver
everything you need right to you dua and
they keep you fully stocked on what you
use so you don't run out here's how it
works by the way one wipe charlie is not
accurate okay you don't just do one wipe
what it is is you use the toilet paper
first and then the one wipe Charlie gets
rid of any evidence that anything went
down okay it's like the poor man's bidet
okay you heard he here first
you're probably going to hear it here
last just make sure I get some sort of
credit Dollar Shave Club has everything
you need to get ready no matter what
you're getting ready for they have you
covered head to toe for your hair hey
your skin your face you name it they
have it and they have this new program
where they automatically keep you
stocked up on the products you use you
determine what you want and when you
want it and it shows up right at your
door well Jesus Christ I hope you get
out and exercise if it's that easy do
they have like a white for your
underneath your Mantid from one Sun for
one from once a month to once every six
months plus with their handsome discount
hi fellas the more you buy the more you
save and right now Dollar Shave Club has
a bunch of starter sets you can try for
just five dollars like their oral care
kit after that the restock box ships
regular size products at regular price
get your status set for just five
dollars right now at dollarshaveclub.com
slash bar b you are r that's
dollarshaveclub.com slash bar b you are
r alright and with that
talk Super Bowl for the final three and
a half map I don't know what the [ __ ]
gonna happen I have this I kind of feel
like it's gonna be I feel he's gonna be
like a lot of these NFL games where you
got two high-powered offenses and
they're gonna be like this is gonna be a
high-scoring game and I think it's gonna
be low scoring for the first half and
then it's just gonna be a [ __ ] [ __ ]
show in the second half and it's gonna
be one of those things whoever has the
ball last wins you know or it could be
like last Super Bowl where the defenses
are a complete non factor and to the
point all that has to happen is you're
if whatever defense makes a play you
just need to make one [ __ ] play and
then and then boom then you win the game
that's what I think that's what I think
cuz I think last year's Super Bowl
rather than being one of the ugliest
[ __ ] games I've ever watched in my
life I literally felt like I was
watching a third grade Pop Warner game
with the complete lack of [ __ ]
defense in that game I I'm now realized
that that was not an anomaly that that
is now the way the game is played and
that's the way it has to be played
because if you don't then these poor
people that are playing the [ __ ] game
are gonna you know have this CTE [ __ ] so
I've accepted it that's the way it is
and you know I don't know that's just I
don't know so that that it that is my
feeling I am I'm not believing on any
level that Todd Gurley isn't gonna play
and it's not gonna you know [ __ ] get
a bunch of yards and I also feel like
their quarterback whatever his [ __ ]
name is
I forget he doesn't give a [ __ ] that
it's a Super Bowl he's gonna come out
there cool as a cucumber I will say this
about all these new [ __ ] quarterbacks
they don't give a [ __ ] that they were in
the Super Bowl you know Nick Foles last
year et he's like he was playing catch
in the backyard the first ball he threw
was like this guy doesn't give a [ __ ]
this is gonna be a long day
love Nick Foles I'm trying to think the
last time I saw quarterback get looked
nervous they just come I am a rookie I
threw 50 touchdowns Patrick my home's a
you want 50 more hey who wants to score
next [ __ ] throne its sidearm and [ __ ]
they don't give a [ __ ] they're all
coming in like Clint Eastwood in the
spaghetti westerns you know staring at
three guys with your little [ __ ]
cigarette ah you know cigar Arella
whatever the [ __ ] you used to smoke they
just come in and they just [ __ ] they
just light them up so I think yep so I
have no prediction I just hope my team's
gonna win I haven't watched enough
football to even remotely try to break
the game down all I can do is break down
what I'm gonna be doing which is making
burgers and dogs and not sitting down
and pacing the entire [ __ ] time but
uh I think it's cool that the Rams are
back in LA and they got the blue and
yellow helmets I like that [ __ ] oh the
blue and white I guess they went back to
the one they had in the 60s but uh I
like that [ __ ] and I think the Raiders
should stay in Oakland even though
moving to Vegas is gonna be a great
thing oh this could be a great thing can
you imagine how many people like their
last thing they're gonna do after they
kill their wife in Vegas is to go to a
Raiders game before they let out and
cuffs at halftime I mean it's gonna be
like it's gonna happen a lot you know or
choke a hooker or whatever the [ __ ]
they're gonna do and that's seedy little
town the [ __ ] nerve of the NFL to
throw out Dave Portnoy for asking that
gambling Qui guess because he didn't
have a he didn't have a parking pass or
whatever the [ __ ] you need to get into
that thing anyways but I just think it's
so funny how much they [ __ ] annoy and
irritate the NFL they're sitting there
acting like they're a decent
organization all the [ __ ] all the
[ __ ] crap that they've done I love it
I love her so God God bless the fellas
over at barstool sports all right so
what is it here it's uh there's your
half-hour
put the [ __ ]
I run a sports website put the [ __ ]
cuffs on me I'll take over the prison I
would have been the exact opposite
please don't put them on me I'm sorry
all right that is the podcast please
enjoy the music here and then the
greatest hits and all that [ __ ] coming
up another half-hour of [ __ ] stuff
here and then of a Thursday yeah another
half-hour of a former shelf that I did
about a Thursday afternoon podcast and
everybody I will I'm getting ready
Oh Billy's get ready he can't read the
word bread or breed he's getting ready
to do is special so where are you doing
your special I should take my special at
a woman's college I'm doing Santa
Barbara Pasadena Riverside tickets on
sale now on February 15th 16th 17th
Santa Barbara Pasadena Riverside who
were your opening acts
Jason lawhead is gonna be in Santa
Barbara
Joe bartnik Pasadena and Nate Craig and
Riverside that's it it's the white male
tour I'm going old school here alright
go [ __ ] yourselves enjoy the weekend you
[ __ ] and I'll talk to you after the
superball either be in a great mood or a
very subdued mood one of the other but
I'll see you on Monday
there's a video that affects a lot of
people cetme this week it was about
these these [ __ ] Bank of [ __ ]
they're let's see what little is it here
this isn't the BBC News
HSBC imposes restrictions on large cash
withdrawals all right and so at a HSBC
customers have been prevented some
customers have ever been prevented from
withdrawing large amounts of cash
because they could not provide evidence
of why they wanted it the BBC has
learned isn't it learned as a learnt
anyways listeners have told radios fors
moneybox not to be confused with
nature's box they were stopped from
withdrawing amounts ranging from five
grand of five thousand pounds to ten
thousand pounds HSBC admitted it has not
informed customers of the change in
policy policy which was implemented in
November the bank says it has now
changed its guidance to staff so
basically this guy went down there said
can I have my five thousand pounds that
I earned and I put in this Bank for
safety they said no he said can I have
four thousand pounds they said no and
then I wrote one out I guess when uh
withdrawal slip for three thousand
pounds and they said okay we'll give you
that blah blah blah blah blah blah so
they got a bunch of bad press so now
allegedly they're changing it so a bunch
of people said you know what's the
[ __ ] with these banker [ __ ] you know
it's it's our money yadda yadda yadda
and all that [ __ ] I Got News for you
it's not your money all right it's their
money they print it it's theirs okay and
your job is to take the money that they
give you for working your ass off all
week and your job is to then take that
money and give it back to them or get
your ass into debt with it think about
you work all [ __ ] weekend what do I
do you even hold money in your [ __ ]
hand anymore they give it to you on this
[ __ ] piece of paper alright I know a
lot of people rolling their eyes right
now bouquet
I got a point at the end of this [ __ ]
okay you take it down into these [ __ ]
and you just give it to them now this is
the thing the reason why it's not like
the reason why they didn't give that
person the 10,000 pounds do you know why
they didn't give it to him it's because
they don't have it I'm not saying that
they don't physically have 10,000 pounds
in the bank yes they do but they don't
have 10,000 pounds available to give to
it just some random jackass who goes oh
by the way I want to take ten thousand
pounds out right [ __ ] now they don't
have it well I don't know about how it
works in England but as far as in the
United States they don't have it for the
simple fact that when if you went down
and you deposit some regular [ __ ] Tom
Dick Harry or Louise and you deposit ten
grand into a bank back in the old days
when there was some sort of rules and
regulations governing these
out-of-control [ __ ] when you ran a bank
you you had on your books like you could
only loan out a certain percentage of
the money or the bank was in violation
like like Saint let's just say to make
it easy they're a million dollars was
deposited into your bank you could only
that during that time you could only
loan out I don't know what the
percentage was but it was like 300 grand
of it four hundred grand I forget what
the percentage was but you could you
could you couldn't go past a certain
tipping point because god forbid if
there was a run on money and everybody
started withdrawing the bank would fail
now any bank if everybody shows up and
tries to take the money out is gonna
fail because you know they they they
loan out a certain percentage of it all
right but throughout the years they kept
pushing that percentage up more and more
and more and more to the point that they
got up - not only can they loan out a
hundred percent of the deposits from the
hard work and the people that deposit
the money in there they can actually
then create another two million dollars
off that million something like that
like so if you deposit 10 grand they can
take your full 10 grand loaning out plus
another 10 grand off that 10 grand plus
another 10 grand off that 10 grand so
they basically just invented /
counterfeited 20 grand that didn't even
[ __ ] exist off that 10 grand they got
30 grand and loaned out so they can make
the money off that [ __ ] 20% interest
off of that kicking you half a percent
in your [ __ ] account and they just
sit there knowing full well at some
point whatever bubble they're creating
is gonna burst [ __ ] is going to hit the
fan you're gonna be ass out and they're
too big to fail and at worst case
scenario that you're going after a
corporation and what are they they're
just they're just they're faceless
corporation is faceless they take their
bonuses is just sitting there waiting
for John Cougar Mellencamp to write you
a [ __ ] song that [ __ ] jackass aid
and they're out there buying a new
[ __ ] yacht all right did that make
sense and I know you guys are gonna be a
girl you're full of [ __ ] blah blah blah
blah you don't know what the [ __ ] you're
talking about you sound like a [ __ ]
hey I'll take all of that but I'm gonna
tell you this for like the [ __ ]
hundredth time in my stand-up career
when I was in Albuquerque I had a banker
come up to me and was laughing going I
know you hate us and I said listen am i
a [ __ ] in the podcast and they always
say no they go no you're not you know
this of some factual errors a little bit
here or there but basically what you're
saying is 100% true I talk conspiracy
theory one time in my own bank as I was
trying to set something up new on my
account I was talking to a banker about
conspiracy theory and he was talking
about banking he was talking about how
scary and [ __ ] up it was and he was
asking me what I planned to do what do
you think about gold and silver coins
what do you think about growing zucchini
and I was the most tech news whispering
and [ __ ] I'm telling you and I have no
solutions so what I'm really being right
now was a [ __ ] fear monger but this
is this is the great thing about banking
is that you know I would say a good 95
percent of people walking around with
the [ __ ] god
Tootsie Pop in their mouth pulling their
[ __ ] Hawaiian shorts out of their ass
crack believe in it alright and as long
as they continue to believe in it you
can kind of exist in the game drafting
behind they're uninformed I don't know
what the [ __ ] word is I'm too stupid
to do this but you just basically like I
am of the belief that if you can get a
[ __ ] house buy one that you can
afford and then pay that [ __ ] down as
soon as you can and all of that [ __ ]
that people say where they go oh it's
not an investment because you go to the
dude [ __ ] that pay off your [ __ ]
house and then if the bank fails you
still have a house who gives a [ __ ] if
you paid 700 grand for it now it's only
worth the hundred grand you still have a
house as much as that sucks at least you
still have it like the [ __ ] stock
market right you work your whole goddamn
life you stick it in that stick it in
this over there when you think you're
being conservative the thing shits the
bed and in the end you can be left with
nothing so I am into tension huh
tangible [ __ ] can you tell I screamed
whenever I do a podcast the day after I
went to a game or I did a lot of shows I
sound like I'm going through puberty
again I apologize but I believe in
investing in tangible [ __ ] and don't let
your wife or your husband be like oh we
go could we go we're gonna save up for
the college education you know what [ __ ]
their college education all right take
out a loan take out a [ __ ] what
you're paying interest on your house now
the amount of money that you're gonna
save knocking down your principal will
pay for most if not all of their college
education all right unless they just go
to some unbelievably expensive school
and you're I don't know living in some
Little House on the Prairie
Michael Landon smoking a pipe so there
you go so that's why that's why when
they go down there
because they they're not going to give
ten grand or ten pounds to the average
jackass walking in there because that
starts [ __ ] with their game which is
pretending that all the money is there
and that it's it's safe and that there's
nothing to worry about and nothing to
see here so what they do is they pull
this [ __ ] and they bully people
individually over in the corner behind
that bulletproof glass and they're like
no you have to get a note in blah blah
blah blah blah and most people like they
have a parent-child relationship their
entire life they come out as a child
their parents tell them what to do what
they can and can't do when they can eat
when they have to go to bed and they go
off into the world you know you go to
school we're going to lunch now
you have a question raise your hand and
you you stay in that mentality so to the
point you have a [ __ ] adult who
earned the money will go into a bank you
know God bless this person who actually
[ __ ] was like no this is my money and
complain and brought this out to light
but do you think this is the only person
they did that to the money's not there
man yeah like if you had like two 300
grand in an account you decide that you
just want to [ __ ] take it out like if
you physically want the money if you
want to transfer it like [ __ ] numbers
hit enter they'll [ __ ] do that all
day uh yeah no worries but if you
actually wanted the paper like you can't
just walk in there and be like yes I'd
like my 300 grand and they'd be like
okay and come out big sacks of money you
got to call them days if not a week in
advance and then what they got to do is
frantically call around in front find an
armored car with enough of this paper
that isn't worth [ __ ] other than the
fact that the guy with the underwear in
his ass still believes in it they got to
drive that there so they can physically
keep the lie going all right there you
go so that's the end of Mike my [ __ ]
bar room banking 101 alright
and you know I don't give a [ __ ] about
your opinions either because I'm not
enlightened as a human being if you
don't agree with what I said then you
know just laugh at me and continue on
with your [ __ ] day because you're
actually helping me out as long as you
keep [ __ ] believing in it but I think
the day the wave hitting the beach is
coming soon because you know at least in
this country I mean the government shut
down for three [ __ ] days and I know
made for great stand-up material but
that is absolutely [ __ ] terrifying
every year when August comes around and
we hit the debt ceiling and we just keep
raising it and we just keep pushing more
of [ __ ] under the bed like eventually
it's not all I don't know it's probably
the wrong analogy I don't know what the
[ __ ] were doing but eventually this [ __ ]
is gonna hit the fan so I'm not saying
I'm gonna survive it whatever the [ __ ]
happens but I do have a game plan my
game plan is to pay off my house as
quickly as I can
so when the first wave of people are
being brought to the I don't know what
euphemism they're gonna be using for
detention camps I figure it'll be like
well you can't pay off your house for
repossessing the house so now we're
gonna move you to alternative relaxing
living whatever the [ __ ] they're gonna
call it at least I won't be in that
first wave of people I will have my
house paid off and I will stand there
dressed like a court jester with my
little fancy cane going but get off my
property and then look at me be like
look at those little [ __ ] thing NES
power all right we'll be back for you
we'll be back for your like a month or
so let's just get the let's get the
mouth-breathers first let's get the easy
people then we'll weed out the red [ __ ]
and then it'll all be ours so it's about
ties in to how they're trying to make
robots more and more human-like all
right this is the kind of [ __ ] this
story right here that seems like a
victory for the common man and what it
really is is this just moving the ball
forward on the development of robots
they can eventually phase us out and
then they can just have robot people
that will never never complain then of
course if you watch science fiction
movies they somehow take over the humans
which they're not going to do they're
not gonna do that alright we made you
alright
we'll unplug you we won't fix you I'll
dump some water on you you know this is
the deal every [ __ ] web designer when
he builds your website or he builds you
a secure site always builds in a [ __ ]
backdoor alright so the guys making the
robots are gonna do the same [ __ ]
thing
there's no way Lee Illuminati is gonna
have a bunch of robots that are stronger
than them don't need to sleep and all
that type of [ __ ] and like they watch
science fiction movies these [ __ ] are
science fiction how crazy do I sound
this week I'm actually enjoying every
[ __ ] second of this they're gonna
have a back door you know somewhere up
there robots ask there's got to be
something that they can [ __ ] do some
button they have to push all right so
there you go was that weird enough for
you huh I'm sorry what do you want from
me you know my [ __ ] weird guy
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it is the Monday morning podcast from
Monday January 31st 2011 how are you how
are you doing really oh that's good to
hear you know I was worried about you
yeah you know something you see it just
goes to show you doesn't it it just goes
to show you that if you sit around and
you think positive thoughts you'll have
a happy Monday
are you having a happy Monday happy
Monday to you I'm not having a happy
Monday I [ __ ] flew back from Dallas
Texas which is why the podcast is a
little bit late among other [ __ ]
technology goddamn reasons because I
bought a new [ __ ] microphone and I
brought it out to Texas with me and it
just picked up the entire room and I did
a whole [ __ ] podcast and I was gonna
upload it like a good boy midnight so
even my friends over there in jolly old
England way back over there and Sweden
and even those couple of [ __ ] that
listened in Mongolia would have
something on a Monday morning wherever
the [ __ ] they're at what happened I went
back and I listened to it and it sounded
like ass and I was like I'm not
subjecting my listeners to this how do
you like that like that isn't that a
great excuse for being late I'm late
because I was thinking about you I was
thinking about your needs I think I care
too much um oh god I feel like [ __ ] I
forgot to bring my vitamins with me
right I'm such a [ __ ] old man did
that [ __ ] just hit the floor
down there I think now I'm just hearing
things [ __ ] that old guy and his balls
yeah I don't forgot to bring my vitamins
speaking of old I have to bring vitamins
with me when I'm on the road now you
know I can't [ __ ] do it anymore if
the years of breathing in that airline
food listen listen to my voice right now
right a lot of the ladies probably
thinks it's you know sounds a little bit
sexy it is this is what I sound like
when I'm beginning to get sick
and I forgot all my [ __ ] you know all my
pills I'm late oh man
all my pills that I [ __ ] take when
I'm on the road so I don't get sick you
know you fly out I'm always flying back
[ __ ] East you know so then I got to
get up at 6:00 in the morning which is
really like 4:00 in the morning for me
then I do radio then I try to come back
and go to sleep but the [ __ ] sun's
out I can't do it then I do my shows and
then I'm [ __ ] shaking everybody's
hands afterwards and then I [ __ ] you
know rub my face you know and next thing
you know I got road AIDS you know but
it's curable it's curable by [ __ ]
three shitty days sitting in your own
[ __ ] apartment it's my big
announcement for the week people I have
Road AIDS the first known case of 2011
it's early this year and you know is my
fault
I didn't protect myself so yeah I'm a
little under the weather this week so
but I'm gonna [ __ ] bring it like
Jerry Lewis you know who never sat down
in his tuxedo pants so I'm laying down
right now so I'm gonna try to bring the
[ __ ] funny let me tell you about my
weekend all right people I went out to
Dallas Tacey yeah Dallas Texas I went
out that way
and I performed at the new Improv in
Arlington Texas despite the fact that
kept saying I was in Addison on last
week's product podcast I was in
Arlington did any of you guys
accidentally go to Addison you would
have been disappointed you would have
saw earthquake a [ __ ] good friend of
mine someone I highly recommend you go
see live [ __ ] you wanna hear one of
[ __ ] great off the top of his head
off the top of your [ __ ] headline
that I saw him do one time what a [ __ ]
worthy we were some [ __ ] room in the
Bronx of some [ __ ] I can't remember was
one of those [ __ ] clubs where like
two days after we did it it got shut
down cuz somebody shot off a pistol in
there was one of those [ __ ] things
you know back when I was like I'm gonna
do the psycho it's rooms ever you know
and then I won't be nervous when I'm
doing Letterman well you know what it
doesn't work that way
you just get used to doing shitty rooms
but then when you go to do Letterman
you're like oh wait
this is this is a different kind of
pressure that kind of pressure
is well no one's paying attention how
the [ __ ] can I get these people to
listen but then it's kind of easy cuz
it's like well then that's you know it's
supposed to suck so if you do okay then
people like wow that was amazing
but if you do Letterman you're supposed
to do well everybody's paying attention
they got the air conditioner on
everybody's facing forward right
whatever so I'm in this [ __ ] room
trying to figure out what the [ __ ] I'm
gonna say to try to get I try to get the
crowd going before they realize how
disgustingly white I am which they're
gonna see before him get to the [ __ ]
mic stand what's his face earthquake was
on stage wait was this an Atlanta I
can't [ __ ] remember anymore so
whatever I was doing some [ __ ] room
right and he was up there killing and he
looked over in the crowd and there was a
woman sitting in there this large woman
who was not good-looking okay I'm not
trying to be mean but her face was a
mess
okay I'm talking like a Rottweiler with
a dress and she had one of those big you
know those African hats it kind of looks
like the Pope hat but it's more looks
sort of like a vase and it just goes
straight up you know didn't one of those
early rappers with the giant chunky gold
chains did she wear one of those you and
I D why that's a unity did she wear one
of those so anyways the girl is sitting
in the crowd and he's in the middle of
killing and the second he sees her he's
in the middle of telling a joke he just
says he called her erykah ba-don't
it was one of the funniest and meanest
[ __ ] things I said was [ __ ]
brilliant it was right off the top of
his head but it was so [ __ ] mean
because she didn't say anything and you
know she really didn't deserve it but it
was just what I liked about it was he
didn't point at her he just looked at
her and just to himself when Erica Budd
don't and you know the people in that
section knew and they just [ __ ] that
without what's what I liked about it
was he he just said it he said I don't
give a [ __ ] that only people sitting cuz
you know the rest of crowd couldn't see
her whatever so whatever I [ __ ] up if
you went to the Edison improv you saw
earthquakes so there you go there you go
but anyways I was out in Arlington Texas
this week to go out there to the the
Texas Oklahoma area with those girls
with the huge faces in the big heads and
I saw a lot of them saw a lot of
big-headed Texas girls I saw a lot of
cutie pies too one way or the other out
there they're either [ __ ] drop-dead
gorgeous gorgeous or they just have
these [ __ ] Mount Rushmore heads hair
teased up cuz it's Dallas everything's
big and Dallas just giant Fred
Flintstone [ __ ] heads that doesn't
stop him from teasing up their hair they
look like those Texas girls with the big
heads when they're done with the eye
shadow teasing up their hair they look
like [ __ ] Nikki Sixx do you realize
the [ __ ] balls I have to attack how
anybody looks do you understand that
a balding [ __ ] redhead do you
understand the level of [ __ ] balls
that that takes alright so anyways the
first night I fly him and you know the
club owner out there he's a little fella
you know stands about 4 foot 11 he's
adorable
you know likes to dress a little [ __ ]
shiny shirts you know just just the
little fella
you know scoots his seat right up to the
steering wheel you know scoop just see
all of it is is is far up as you could
possibly scoot a seat and his arms are
still straight when he's holding onto
the [ __ ] steering wheel I'm just
being a dick and Casey's listening um so
anyways he picks me up right and we went
right to the [ __ ] Dallas Mavericks
Houston Rockets game sat right behind
the [ __ ] this is how great my weekend
was sat right behind the Houston Rockets
bench okay well actually there's the
bench and then there's the [ __ ] guys
who hand them the water bottles then
there was a [ __ ] quart little alley
and then there was us it was [ __ ]
ridiculous
all right and I'm sitting now getting to
see all this [ __ ] you don't get to see
when you watch a game on TV like towards
the end of the [ __ ] game
I saw you knows one of those deals where
they needed two scores
you know don't shoot a three just get it
quick two and then try and foul do that
[ __ ]
so the [ __ ] point guard goes you know
what I don't see any other teammates I
guess it's all up to me for some reason
he decided to do this and one [ __ ]
right [ __ ] in one of the most
spectacular missed layups you've ever
seen in your [ __ ] life if you did a
percentage of the odds of the [ __ ]
thing going in it was probably even with
a good NBA player like a 40% shot that's
what the [ __ ] he took when they needed
they needed a big score right didn't
even look just brought it up the court
did it all himself all right and [ __ ]
missed it and I immediately see you know
cuz I'm sitting there I saw the coaching
staffs reaction they just had you know
you have one [ __ ] Slater drop that
ball and Super Bowl [ __ ] 13 and Roger
Staubach went ah just [ __ ] that's
what they did all three of them in
unison like backup dancers did the exact
same thing just looked over their left
[ __ ] shoulder and then they all went
over and they sat down on the bench like
well this [ __ ] games over okay so the
Rockets quickly foul someone on the
Mavericks they go up to the line I think
the [ __ ] point guard did it cuz he's
standing up there by half-court and I
see him calling over the coaches he's
going head coach he goes should I file
you want me to file and the coach won't
even look at him and then I see the
player in the coat on the floor just
rolls his eyes like a [ __ ] I'm gonna
[ __ ] hear about this one right that's
how close I was I'm sitting there I'm
absolutely giddy to the left of me to
the right of me I'm sorry we're three
ladies right
they weren't even hot they were like
sort of hot you know they did all this
[ __ ] that hot girls do they had fancy
clothes they had on the eyeliner they
teased up their hair but they take just
were you know you know when you watch
American light Idol and someone can
almost sing kind of like the way I sing
picture the way I see
I'm almost there listen row row row your
boat gently down the stream yeah I just
said stray right that's the kind of good
looking they are you all right it was it
wasn't that bad right up to stray that's
what happens yeah that ass isn't bad
those titties aren't that bad either
then you look at that face strain you're
like [ __ ] really how the [ __ ] you
sitting this close so not only were they
sitting there they weren't [ __ ]
paying attention this is why I am
[ __ ] I don't know if the word is
racist I don't know if it's it's not
racist good-looking women is it's not
it's not a racial thing I don't know if
I'm sexist now cuz it's not a woman
thing it's a specific kind of [ __ ] I
just I [ __ ] beautiful women I don't
you know you know when you go to the
golf course you know what guys tee off
in my [ __ ] mental world versus where
the women tee off in my world
mentally beautiful women they they got a
tee off way back there they got to go
that extra [ __ ] 30 goddamn yards cuz
I just immediately assume that you're
gonna be exactly like these [ __ ]
[ __ ] who was sitting next to me they
sat there and they had their [ __ ]
stupid noisemakers right which is always
a sign of a bad franchise by the way
I've said this for [ __ ] years and for
some reason some of you are you're not
hearing me okay if you're fans suck so
bad that they have to give them
noisemakers so they can sound like a
[ __ ] enthusiastic crowd okay
noisemakers like it's [ __ ] New Year's
Eve or some [ __ ] right so they're
sitting there I took a picture of it and
it's gonna be up on the mmm podcast by
the way the girl next to me is holding
her two little thunder sticks in her
left hand and sorry my voice is [ __ ]
up in her left hand and then she's
texting on her blackberry with her thumb
and that Blackberry is wrapped in this
little hot pink [ __ ] just annoy the
[ __ ] out of me and at one point somebody
throws an alley-oop for this monster
[ __ ] dunk the crowd goes crazy she
misses the whole [ __ ] thing she sets
down her blackberry and then starts
clapping the thunder sticks together
just because he hears the crowd and
just goes yay and then put then went
right back to what the [ __ ] she was
doing yeah it shouldn't it annoyed me
but it did it annoyed me and then at one
point her the two other horror friends
kept yelling over at somebody who worked
from the madrix they were going Mitch
Mitch Mitch you know they do that in
Dallas they'll take a one syllable word
and they make it I can make it to like
I'm going to beg it they go make it and
I look over and Mitch turns out to be
one of these jackasses who comes running
out like sort of skipping and running at
the same time with one of those guns and
he shoots [ __ ] t-shirts up into the
upper deck you know you know those
[ __ ] guys you ever want to just punch
someone in the face more when you see
them with their eyebrows up and they're
pointing up at the upper deck like huh
you want a free t-shirt do it yeah they
do that stupid little skip step you know
across the court and then they stop you
know feet parallel to each other and
then they just stick one hand up in the
air and the girls do this and then they
sort of jump in a circle waving it's
just it's you know first of all it's
embarrassing to watch people freak out
that much about a [ __ ] free t-shirt
you know it's like what is it [ __ ]
ten bucks go buy one people up there
hangin up I'm telling you someone's
gonna fall out of that [ __ ] upper deck
and they're gonna it's gonna be the
dumbest death ever and I'm gonna laugh
and I'm gonna watch it on YouTube and
I'm gonna have no sympathy for the
person cuz you're it's a t-shirt so
anyways he turns out he's one of these
guys and he wasn't really a good-looking
guy you there but he works for the
Mavericks so he has three sort of
hotties you know unfortunately with guys
it's not how you look it's it's it's the
position you're in in life he just
doesn't realize it that he could have
got three better-looking women but you
know he's too busy looking at his uh
imperfections when he brushes his teeth
that's what I think did that story go
off the rails I think it did
then I did my [ __ ] shows at the at
The Improv he had great shows and then
Sunday I'm sitting around doing not a
and the Oklahoma City Thunder had a game
against the [ __ ] in my
me heat okay and I'm like well I live in
Los Angeles if I wanted to sit down
close to see the Miami Heat at a [ __ ]
Lakers game I mean I'm gonna have to
[ __ ] shell out two grand and blow
Hugh Hefner so [ __ ] it I'm gonna go up
there you know what face value for the
tickets were face value I was sitting
behind the goal where Chris Bosh and
[ __ ] Durant got in each other's faces
I was sitting behind that goal about
[ __ ] I don't know 15 rows up they
yelled really loudly I could hear what
the [ __ ] they were saying you know what
face value when those tickets was fifty
five bucks
underrated going to a sporting event in
[ __ ] Oklahoma alright don't sleep on
those in the middle of nowhere [ __ ]
cities it's great the cost of living is
so much lower ticket prices are [ __ ]
lower and you can sit down low like you
[ __ ] Ben Stiller or some [ __ ] well 20
rows behind where he would be sitting
and then I'm also on the side and I
couldn't see part of it because the
[ __ ] goal was in the way but other
than that it was great and I got to tell
you underrated also is the [ __ ]
Oklahoma Thunder uh [ __ ] fans man
they had great fans and they had a
phenomenal [ __ ] stadium it was
bare-bones it was like reverse Staples
Center so and the tickets were cheap and
people you know could afford to go and
they had a big upper deck and they only
had one row of luxury boxes so it was
loud as hell it was way louder than the
[ __ ] Staples Center um you know and I
actually liked it better than the
[ __ ] goddamn Banknorth fleet garden
whatever the [ __ ] they call that back in
Boston that awful arena those two
[ __ ] legendary franchises the Bruins
and the Celtics and that's the [ __ ]
arena that you build them you go down to
Home Depot and you buy 16,000 cinder
blocks and you just make a big [ __ ]
square that's what that's what we get
you know we had this unbelievable home
ice home court advantage back in the day
and I feel like I'm in a food court when
I'm in that [ __ ] place so so anyways
yeah I was sitting right there when they
were talking [ __ ] and evidently
Kevin Durant went off on him afterwards
said he was one of those fake tough guys
and it was all the big [ __ ] gossip
around the NBA and I was there I was
[ __ ] psyched and I know you guys
think I'm [ __ ] nuts for doing that
[ __ ] what else was I gonna do sit in my
hotel room
tell the featur act to pick me up and go
take me to get some [ __ ] barbecue I I
can't do it anymore you know I went up
there you know what's great about that
that drive from Dallas to to Oklahoma
City is it's in between the two cities
when you're in the middle of [ __ ]
nowhere right and he go you go over the
Red River which I didn't even know I was
gonna go to the Red River Rivalry game
last year all right I don't even know
what the [ __ ] Red River was I don't
know what it was what cuz they they kick
the [ __ ] out of each other and there's a
river of blood afterwards I had no
[ __ ] idea evidently that's that river
that runs along the south of the state
that gives it its its its shape right so
you [ __ ] go over that River and then
that's when all the signs about Jays is
they all start coming out I took one
creepy [ __ ] photo this was outside of
a gas station where the [ __ ] is my phone
like that's the type of [ __ ] you know
you're driving down the street right and
you know I saw at one point they were
like four crosses on the side of the
road four we're like I guess four people
died in a goddamn accident I don't know
they [ __ ] sideswiped an ox or some
[ __ ] I mean it was like in the middle
it's like the middle of [ __ ] nowhere
and when the hell wasn't at that time I
did that podcast and I was telling you
that that guy oh I know when you drive
from [ __ ] Cincinnati down to
Nashville somewhere in Kentucky can
somebody send me a picture of this
somebody has the Ten Commandments
written out in signage on the Steve the
outskirts of his of his of his farm
it's really [ __ ] frightening let me
see if I can find this here I'm
scrolling you know you get out that yeah
it's all [ __ ] about Jesus or it's or
it's a it's a farm or it's a casino oh
here it is here it is we pulled over for
gas what does this sign say
his blood paid all you know it's like
can I enjoy my [ __ ] day
can I just drive up and go see a
basketball game without you bringing up
the fact that somebody got tortured to
death so I can somehow make it to [ __ ]
lala land which I'm not going to I'm not
gonna make it right you've heard the
podcast you think God doesn't have
iTunes I'm [ __ ] there's no way I'm
making it I don't even buy into that
[ __ ] you know somebody last week you
know cuz I went off on [ __ ] J star
there last week right the [ __ ] boss
his son
don't [ __ ] Twinkle Toes himself the
originator of the bergen stock [ __ ]
look that guy you know later went on to
play bass in nirvana right isn't that
what Jesus did
that's the reason already came back you
guys missed it
what was the [ __ ] was I talking about I
was on such a great little [ __ ]
tangent there and I to bring up Nirvana
what the [ __ ] did I do that for all
right pill you ever do this [ __ ] when
you care when were you talking about
that you gotta back it up in your head
alright his blood for you oh I know yeah
yeah I somebody last week sent me this
[ __ ] email you see if I can find this
[ __ ] it was hilarious because he had in
the subject in all capital letters it
just said answer me right and I didn't
know if it was somebody [ __ ] around
or what but it was some dude who was
annoyed by me taking the Lord's name in
vain
there it is answer me bill here we go
it's from a guy I know I don't say names
but what what are the odds that some
Jesus Freak would ever first name Travis
I wish you would stop using Jesus
Christ's name in vain no G what do you
have against religion anyway I think you
are confused about the whole thing
attend a good bible-believing Church
talk to the pastor and actually listen
to him I like how he assumes that I
talked to a pastor I didn't listen
did you catch that little
passive-aggressive talk to the past and
once you [ __ ] listen this time I
would really appreciate it if you would
be open about Jesus and Christianity it
will change your life
exclamation point guarantee explanation
point yet spelled wrong he spelled
guarantee gu ra NT just names Travis gon
take I'm telling you get the jay-z's
it's gonna change your life what are you
have against well let me let me read
back this and let me give it the most
stereotypical horrific [ __ ] accent I
can I wish you'd stop using Jesus name
in vain what do you have against
religion anyway I find it oppressive
that's what I don't like about it I
don't like how they use fear how they
try to scare the [ __ ] out of me since
the day I'm [ __ ] born I don't even
[ __ ] sit there and act like they don't
they do it's [ __ ] annoying they don't
know what happens to you when you die so
stop scaring the [ __ ] out of me I think
you go right to the [ __ ] ground
that's what you do and you [ __ ] you
make the soil richer right and then next
thing you know there's a mosquito flying
out of it thanks to you it works for all
of us the United Way right that's what I
think I don't have a problem with
religion okay I [ __ ] on it the way I
[ __ ] on everything else why do you just
[ __ ] send me emails when I want to
talk about old J star there you know
tend a good bible-believing Church I did
I did it my whole [ __ ] life and you
know what turned out they were [ __ ]
kids you know do you understand that
Travis do you understand what they did
to society the amount of [ __ ] just
people who came forward and how that's
gonna affect the person that they they
marry and the way they raised their
[ __ ] kids and the hang-ups that
they're gonna have that [ __ ] is gonna
last for [ __ ] centuries okay you
forget about the [ __ ] Spanish
Inquisition
all these [ __ ] wars what is rot like
I don't understand these [ __ ] people
who can't see the the ridiculous level
of death
that has been caused because of because
everybody just trying to [ __ ] I'm
really preaching right now I got to shut
up but I dis is just how I feed a smiie
alright I just you know I believe in the
be a good person even though I'm not you
know and I can't even say I'm trying to
be I've quit I've quit trying to be a
good person I've been living in
accordance to the Church of Satan and I
have alright and I know right now you're
thinking I'm in here and I'm [ __ ]
sacrificing a [ __ ] lamb or some [ __ ]
talking to old [ __ ] El Diablo there
I'm not that's not what the Church of
Satan is about that's what the [ __ ] you
guys told me it was about and then one
day back in the day I had a radio show
with young Joe DeRosa the teen idol
sensation from the Opie and Anthony
program and we was Halloween was coming
up we said why don't we have some of
these Satanist people come in here let's
see if they could freak us out so he was
sitting there asking about the devil and
all that and they go yeah we know we
don't believe in that [ __ ]
that's organized religion came up with
that we don't believe we don't believe
that there's a heaven or a hell we don't
believe in the devil we don't believe in
any that stuff so I was like alright so
what do you guys believe it he's just
like basically doing what feels good to
you you know which means you know
[ __ ] banging a bunch of hotties you
want a hot fudge sundae you go on you
[ __ ] eat it if you want peace and
quiet you don't have kids you just you
live for yourself that's basically
that's that's their version of it so
that's what I'm saying I've been living
for myself it's ridiculous alright I
play hockey I played drums I tell jokes
I go to [ __ ] basketball games I'm not
passing any knowledge on to anybody who
half looks like me and half looks like
my beautiful girlfriend I'm living a
very selfish [ __ ] life so but I don't
need Jesus do I Travis is that what
you're yelling right now no that's what
I have against it be I'm you know I got
to make some of this funny all right I
don't have a problem if you're into
organized religion I don't but I
I don't understand why I don't know
people just don't see how that
everything kind of says the same [ __ ]
and then you just have a different guy
that you're you're saying it to and then
for some reason if the other guys don't
believe in your guy eventually you end
up killing them either one-on-one
face-to-face or you let some [ __ ]
tell you what those other people alike
and how they're gonna get you when
they're gonna do all this [ __ ] evil
[ __ ] right and then you go over there
and you [ __ ] kill them while those
[ __ ] rich [ __ ] sit there yeah you
know playing footsie with each other you
know resting their feet on bars of gold
rolling that's what they do they roll
around in cash you know how do they do
you think anything that's what bankers
do just sit there just like change they
just dive into it like a jacuzzi just
coins
creepy giggle um I'm at the [ __ ] top
so that's why Travis alright that's why
I do it cuz I don't [ __ ] believe in
it I don't believe in it I don't believe
a [ __ ] word of it I believe in a
higher power I don't know what the [ __ ]
it is I don't know what happens when you
die but I'm not listening to you or any
other [ __ ] idiot who you know wants
to rub one out to his teacher because
you do alright stop fighting thought you
do just take it out rub it out have a
good [ __ ] time it's your goddamn dick
stop having some other [ __ ] person
tell you what you can jerk off to
alright huh God that was cathartic that
felt good that feel good for you guys
how about you Mitch Mitch Travis Dakota
all right what are we talking about now
what do I got here let's move on to I
gotta read you this [ __ ] hello to
everyone over there in England I know I
keep saying this tour is coming together
it is it is coming together England
Ireland Scotland this [ __ ] thing's
gonna come together and I'm trying to
tack on a Scandinavian tour as well and
then maybe some Australia in the in the
fall
so by all means I love hearing from
other countries all right and I don't
give a [ __ ] if you trash [ __ ] America
I don't give a [ __ ] I just want to hear
what you think I mean I'm not gonna
agree with you on a lot of it but let me
know what's going on over your way so I
can try to make this thing that's so
specific to Jesus freaks in Texas all
right this is from England this is some
sort of sport this is kind of about
sports controversies this week I know if
that was a controversy between Chris
Bosh and guy Kevin Durant all I know was
it was it was great you know I thought
it was awesome I looking they'd get in
each other's face they start [ __ ]
screaming yelling and they played the
game was [ __ ] awesome game and I think
I became a Thunder fan dude by the way
their mascot is the [ __ ] I don't know
what the [ __ ] it is I get I get why that
one doesn't make sense you know what I
mean
like the Phoenix Suns why they have a
gorilla I have no [ __ ] idea I guess a
gorilla like all living things needs the
Sun but other than that that's the only
connection I make with a gorilla and the
[ __ ] Sun so you know whatever San
Diego had the San Diego chicken that
made no [ __ ] sense for the Padres but
the dude was hilarious so anyways this
[ __ ] dude for The Listening his name
is Rumble says his name began with an
are I can't [ __ ] him here but he looks
like where the wild things are one of
those things this [ __ ] dude came out
had his at half-court had his back to
the [ __ ] rim two-handed threw it over
his head without looking with the mascot
[ __ ] on and nothing but net all right
and then walked off the court like it
was nothing and I know he doesn't hit it
every [ __ ] game but it was pretty
goddamn impressive and then later on he
comes out on a [ __ ] drum kit in the
goddamn costume it starts jamming with
these [ __ ] this this mini drumline
killing it and as he's [ __ ] killing
it on the drum kit the drum kit I don't
know how starts going around the [ __ ]
the mini drum line people they're like
standing basically with it where center
court is where the basketball is and
then this thing starts revolving around
it like a goddamn planet around the Sun
like very
fast you know to the point that you know
almost to the point where he could
[ __ ] fall off and he's still keeping
the beat this dude was the [ __ ]
so anyways how the [ __ ] did I get into
that oh I know we're talking sports car
traverses here so this guy sends me the
sink from England this is hilarious
these two guys who basically as far as I
can tell dick they commentate for the
Premier League which is the the the
English soccer league over there for my
money it's the best one out there you
know my little bit of knowledge just
[ __ ] you know 150 years ton of 20 50
years of tradition with some of these
these teams and fans go [ __ ] nuts
people get trampled to death it's it's
everything that you love about sports
right so evidently these commentators
first of all they got busted they didn't
know their mics were on and they was
[ __ ] on this lady who was working on
the sidelines basically not even saying
like like you know I'd love to [ __ ]
bang her basically say and she didn't
know what the [ __ ] she was doing they
just didn't know that their mics were on
so now of course one of them has to step
down and the other ones cast do like
apologize profusely here's basically
what happened you guys got I have the
YouTube videos too you got a you got to
watch these things they're hilarious
I says hey Bill here in England there's
currently a very funny shitstorm
surrounding to Sky Sports Premier League
broadcasters
I'm guessing Sky Sports is like their
their sports channel ESPN or something
so anyways they're they're in trouble
for sexist comments they made about a
female official see I mean I only listen
to her once but I didn't hear them
saying like look at the tits on her they
just said that she stunk at her job you
know has it come to that if he just
criticized a woman for doing a job that
a guy usually does that automatically
become sexist I don't remember them
saying anything like that
granted I'm a [ __ ] [ __ ] but uh I
mean wouldn't these guys know who would
know better than these guys these guys
are the guys right so anyways he says
new footage keeps appearing on YouTube
as people seem to be digging up [ __ ] on
these guys it is well funny as they
a pair of cozy smug [ __ ] who have such
great jobs ah you got a [ __ ] love
English people cozy smug [ __ ] can you
please send me audio of you saying that
and your [ __ ] accent so I can play
for my listeners next week cozy smug
[ __ ] who have such great job is that
what a cozy smug [ __ ] is what a [ __ ]
tremendous description of some douche
who didn't earn his [ __ ] positioned
sits in a corner office hang on a second
I gotta go talk to that cozy smug [ __ ]
down the [ __ ] hotline anyways one has
been one has been sacked that means
fired conspiracy theory is that it's
linked to the fact that he's suing a
sister company newspaper for phone
tapping yeah I don't know what happened
there did someone tap his phone I have
no idea but anyways he goes and the
other one was eating his own balls on
the radio today apologizing like mad
trying to save his career I thought this
story might appeal to you as I know you
love a good broadcaster balls up and a
bit of bit of woman thrashing thrown in
for good measure here are some clips
from the story okay so he gives me the
clips of them making sexist comments I'd
play it for you but you really as an
American got to listen to it a couple of
times to pick up everything that's
saying because they're talking really
fast but the best thing is he sent me
this other clip and it's the same two
broadcasters and they're doing they're
basically speaking over highlights of
women's soccer which as far as I can
tell the quality level is the equivalent
of the WNBA during the first two weeks
that it came out right so they start
doing they start doing the highlights
and these [ __ ] broads
are so bad at playing football that they
just start laughing all right there do
you understand that not in a mean way
it's what made them laugh was the level
of or lack of level of quality of these
[ __ ] broads the way they were playing
the game they
sucked you should see this one [ __ ]
you gotta watch this video have it up on
the mm podcast.com this girl right the
[ __ ] goalie falls down I don't know
what happened she stepped on the string
of her [ __ ] tampon sorry that was
mean she [ __ ] falls down or whatever
she's horrific ly out of position so the
other girl she has basically
three-quarters of the net to shoot this
little [ __ ] ball in on that those you
don't know [ __ ] about soccer a goal in
soccer you could drive three of those
double-decker [ __ ] red London buses
through it so she's got three cue could
drive two [ __ ] buses through it she
kicks the ball somehow she gets
underneath it this thing [ __ ] shoots
up in the air hits underneath the
crossbar comes back out onto the field
of play and then because of the the spin
on the ball it's somehow by the grace of
God trickles into the [ __ ] net it was
one of the ugliest goals ever and then
the girl starts celebrating like she's
[ __ ] Pele or something so I think
that that was a high I can't remember
because I only watched it once these two
[ __ ] cozy smug [ __ ] as this guy says
they start [ __ ] one of them laughs
and then the other one has to continue
talking and then he starts giggling he
now [ __ ] immature guys are next thing
you know they're laughing their balls
off and you know what I saved their job
if one of these [ __ ] broads could
actually play soccer
it wouldn't would stop doing hilarious
horrific [ __ ] on the [ __ ] field or
the pitch or whatever the [ __ ] you call
it you know so these guys got in trouble
for that [ __ ] too
which is hilarious to me and I'm also
thinking why that's why girls suck at
soccer or football whatever the [ __ ] you
call it see if you suck as a guy and
guys laugh at you you have two choices
either get good so they stop laughing at
you or quit the [ __ ] sport you don't
have the option of you stop being me to
me that's sexist stop it and then
everybody has to sit around and pretend
like you don't suck at what you do for a
living
[ __ ] nerve of those broads to get mad
the fat
that that that that that [ __ ] is on TV
is the level of play that that actually
makes it on TV and some guy who's 20
times as good who can't make it into the
Premier League is never gonna get on
television these [ __ ] broads get on
there right and that the level of
[ __ ] play that they put that on when
does that air over there does it come on
right after Benny Hill is it like a
comedy Thursday night I mean the
highlights say literally should have
been playing that way make it a day to
get that [ __ ] kazoo song so anyways
you got to check it out and it's it's
[ __ ] tremendous and I'm not saying
that women are bad athletes but these
women were they were horrific all right
I'm not saying Laila Ali could not beat
the living [ __ ] out of me she could all
right and you know what I would expect
you guys to do laugh your ass off during
the highlight of me getting my ass
kicked because I suck at boxing I'm
terrible at it you know I got a good
temper I'll [ __ ] spaz out and [ __ ]
throw you on the ground if I can you
know start punching you through tears
you know that spasm that type of chefs
what I used to do when I was a kid but I
tried taking boxing I just I I'm not
quick I just I don't have that quick
twitch muscle fiber at all and I have a
huge [ __ ] head so that's not a good
combination slow and having a big head
you don't want to get into a boxing ring
um anyways thank you very much for
sending that and like I said yeah if
you're in any of those those countries
over there that I that I go to which is
basically London London how many more on
England [ __ ] Ireland and Scotland
please send me some Australia I'm coming
your way in any Scandinavian country
alright as far as the rest to you
you know chime in you got a [ __ ]
comedy zone over there eventually I'm
gonna go there and it's not because I
give a [ __ ] about you it's because I see
what the banks are doing they're going
global they're going global and I'm not
gonna get caught flat-footed that's
that's my that's my exit strategy for
when the [ __ ] goes down all right I'm
gonna go out to Van Nuys and hopefully
have a [ __ ] private jet by then and
I'm gonna fess the [ __ ] starts burning
over here I'm gonna jump in a goddamn
plane and flying to another country and
I'm gonna be booking gigs hey remember
me
g'day mate coming down for a couple of
weeks you know booked me in the old
[ __ ] Foster's lager [ __ ] comedy
tour that goddamn [ __ ] that depth
charge level beer evidently none of them
drinking over there oh by the way thanks
for Rupert Murdoch alright thank you
thank you very much Jesus Christ I
thought you guys were cool over there um
you know Rupert Murdoch is such a
douchey almost negates ac/dc
okay there's a [ __ ] statement for you
alright let's let's go on to the next
topic here I have a splitting [ __ ]
headache you even get a headache you can
feel your heartbeat in your ears
alright mm-hmm oh here we go
here's a new topic this topic really
took off this past week the new topic is
this racist racist racist last week we
had some people asking some questions
and I can't [ __ ] remember what the
hell they were I remember I was saying
when I Drive down the street and
somebody cuts me off I play a game out
here in Los Angeles a game called older
Asian and the person I'm riding with we
both have to guess one person picks old
the other person picks Asian you know
and then you pull up alongside and you
take a look and I swear to God 9 times
out of 10 it's one of the other you know
and if it's old an Asian that's like
hitting the green double zero and
[ __ ] roulette nobody wins unless you
picked it unless you said old Asian all
right so I just be like is that [ __ ]
racist right never dealt least somebody
chimed in last week you said it's
actually racist and ageist to say that
so yeah so I guess I have a racist Aegis
game but let me ask you this what about
the factor that it's just me and my car
aren't you allowed to say [ __ ] up [ __ ]
in your car doesn't everybody sort of
become like Michael Douglas and falling
down when you get in your car don't you
say [ __ ] up [ __ ] and when I say don't
you I mean everybody
not just white people come on black
people you know what you say about us
huh you know what you say Mexicans huh
you know what you say everybody knows
what they say everybody says this stuff
Samoans come on you know what you say
when you're out there [ __ ] tackling a
tree and turning it into a [ __ ]
surfboard right there's no what you guys
do are those our toughest [ __ ] people
on the planet I mean my whole knowledge
of Samoans is basically professional
wrestling USC football and that dude on
the Steelers I've just never seen a
[ __ ] [ __ ] who's a Samoan they just
think you know those are like the actual
the real three hundreds people you know
except they're not in the snow you know
they are a bunch of fatty so why don't
they do with Samoans [ __ ] Biggest
Loser that would be the [ __ ] some fat
[ __ ] Samoan dudes you bring him in
there you get him into insane shape and
then at the end of the show rather than
winning like two hundred thousand they
just get drafted into the NFL and they
become millionaires look at that see
that people that's why I moved out to LA
cuz I could just I can create a show out
of nothing can't get it on the [ __ ]
air but I can create one yes I am that a
that is cryptic talk and I'm not ready
to talk about that failure in my career
all right let's plow ahead so here we go
is this racist miss a question I have is
it racist for me to root for a white
running back at this point you know
considering the last good one was like
Jim kick and Larry Csonka John Reagan's
right who's the last that's a kook you
know what I don't know the answer is who
was the last white dude to win the
rushing title all right let me think
here it's definitely nobody and I mean
nobody before Walter Payton there is no
[ __ ] way it was Walter Payton was in
the league earl campbell then came Billy
Sims dick then came into the [ __ ]
league
there was always guys and those guys who
were just they weren't leading the
league but they were still killing it
like Joe Krebs you remember him
who else John Riggins was around them
but I don't think maybe the strike
season did he win it who else came after
that George Rogers Oh Oh Jay Anderson
Tony Dorsett how the [ __ ] died Franco
Harris Rick Upchurch now he wasn't real
isn't running back
Wilbert Montgomery I'm going right
through all the [ __ ] teams they all
had Chuck Muncie and you [ __ ] Jeff Roger
Craig yeah there's no way but they had
that psycho white dude who was [ __ ]
awesome on that team I forget his name
but he wasn't leading the league who was
the last guy all right let's go pre that
then he got who Floyd little Gayle
sayers but getting back to then Jesus
Christ has a white running back ever
done it
I really [ __ ] know so that's what I'm
saying you know it's like it's like what
black people root for like a black
quarterback like all the [ __ ] Asian
people freak out when Hideki Matsui came
to town you know and all of a sudden
they give a [ __ ] about other Yankees cuz
they could thank God they got one of
their guys on there because there's not
there's not a lot of Asian guys in the
major league baseball I didn't look at
them like they were racist so can I can
I be excited about that [ __ ] white
dude who runs for the Cleveland Browns
who has that face mask that looks like
the front of a Dodge Ram truck huh let
me know answer that question I'm gonna
[ __ ] I'm gonna work out all my
[ __ ] on this podcast
all right so evidently older Asian is
ageist and racist that doesn't mean I'm
gonna stop doing it there's no hate my
heart when I do it you know they're
gonna be justifying it as I sit on a
[ __ ] bed with white sheets on it
for comfort okay there's none with holes
in it I'm not putting it on my head all
right so relax all right here we go this
is coming from Japan but these are
actually our troops we have troops based
over there because we're making sure
that no one takes the Japanese people's
freedom that's what we do we just we
we're so concerned about everybody's
freedom around the world that we we
muscle our way in and we put a base
there that's like our Starbucks for the
world we put a base there we just make
sure that everybody's all hunky-dory
looking out for your best interests okay
hey Bill your is it racist segment was
the source of much comedy and pain
yesterday for us out here stationed in
Japan racism is always a source of a
headache and particularly in the
military where great lengths are taken
to ensure that it's not tolerated at all
well that's great that's a good thing
for the most part they do a great job of
course there's always gonna be idiots
everywhere but here's a funny thing that
happened involved involving your
previous podcast somehow I'm [ __ ]
implicated halfway across the world oh
here we go so I'm listening to your
podcast admittedly inappropriately at
work and my coworker who's also black
all right let's stop let's look at the
stats this is a black guy he's hanging
out with another black guy nobody get
nervous uh-huh and my coworker who is
also black and I are laughing at your
crazy ass now this guy is definitely
black cuz I thought how white did that
sound coming out of my voice out of my
mouth I mean out of my voice sorry
people laughing at your crazy ass yo you
did the dobut dubba dubba thing about
the indian reading from one of your fans
letters so my guy is like yeah that [ __ ]
is racist and you know he's gonna get an
email from some idiot asking is would I
pull a click-click-click racist bill I
don't know I don't know what the [ __ ]
that is it some sort of African accent
he goes I mean oh I keep [ __ ] that
thing up actually did this podcast the
other day
and I messed that up let me just read
his entire quote I'm gonna read it as
white as possible so my friend who's
african-american said yeah that [ __ ] is
racist you know he's gonna get an email
from some idiot asking his bully bully
click-click-click
racist bill I mean I know I'm not racist
so I don't know I just don't know here's
where it goes Twilight Zone a woman
passing by in the hallway was evidently
offended by my co-workers insensitive
impression of African dialect so that is
African all right I'm like that Shaka
Zulu right um so she will this
co-workers just walking by his this
dude's talking about my podcast and she
gets offended by the black guy's
impression of an African all right it's
evidently it's a white lady who gets
offended he tried to explain to her that
he was using it as an example and even
offered to play back the portion of the
podcast that it applied to but it seemed
a bit like she was determined to take
advantage of this situation to make some
sort of point so picture this visual
bill a white woman is sitting there
preparing a statement about a black guy
making racist comments about black
people in front of another black guy
myself and all of this being presented
to this section commander who happens to
be japanese-american I'm sitting there
as a witness biting my lip trying not to
laugh because I swear I could see on the
commander's face he was like dear baby
Jesus what the [ __ ] is going on her like
he was trying to blink himself out of
the room in this entire situation so
we'll see where this goes in the
upcoming weeks
he sent me another email and the the
commander there the japanese-american
commander told the African American to
handle it within his he just handled
himself with the Caucasian American
there was that politically correct
enough you hit it on the head in your
last podcast as far as it's what's in
your heart most times
arts to whether or not something is
racist people know [ __ ] all that oh I
was not aware [ __ ] if you say something
or do something and then you wonder if
it's racist or not chances are it
probably is /was if the first thing that
comes out of your mouth is I'm not a
racist or anything but I already know
I'm in for some [ __ ] this the saying
that anything you say well with that
saying anything you say before the word
but is automatically racist and that is
true at least 98% of the time and
nowadays the Internet has just given
people mostly idiots and cowards a voice
of anonymity for [ __ ] like that yeah
that's something I really I is really
depressing is the [ __ ] level of
racist comments on [ __ ] YouTube like
that [ __ ] [ __ ] where no one can see you
no one can get you and you're talking
all that [ __ ] [ __ ] and I don't know
that's depressing
that is really depressing anyways on the
flip side this is the [ __ ] some black
people say about any other race oh [ __ ]
sorry I was doing really well reading
out loud this week when I blow through
this last paragraph I swear to God and
I'll end the torture on the flip side is
this [ __ ] some blacks say about any
other race offensive oh that's not my
fault he wrote that about any other race
offensive and racist of course anyone
that says no is being an idiot I'm a
realist it's why I don't tolerate any
extra hip I grew up around black guys
and I have an NWA cassette tape white
guys saying the n-word around me it's
also why you never hear me say cracker
or any other ethnic slur even in jest
so anyways he's got a question he said
is it racist when you hear a story about
an athlete shooting someone in a strip
club and you assume you know what color
he was maybe to some is it racist when I
hear about a polar bear slapping the
[ __ ] out of someone's kid or a video of
a guy [ __ ] in a girl's mouth and I'm
pretty sure I know what color all of
those people are not oh I'm pretty sure
I know what color all of those people
are not just my two two cents well thank
you for
chiming and that's funny that you bring
up that whole news story because someone
else wrote in to ask me if they thought
that this if this was like a racist game
they said bill I like to play a little
game similar to your Asian or old person
driving game except my game involves in
the evening news it's called [ __ ]
black guy or crazy-ass cracker
just to clarify I am Hispanic
parenthesis Latino Mexican or whatever
other dumbass term someone has come up
with so saying [ __ ] is okay see now
this is why I wanted to do this segment
it's just the exact [ __ ] reason okay
he says [ __ ] black guy and cracker all
right and he goes I can say [ __ ]
because I'm Mexican well then why can
you say cracker ass cracker right it's
because I'm white and no one gives a
[ __ ] about that one see what I'm saying
this is something that I learned from
doing stand-up in front of all different
kinds of people that's what I learned I
learned that everybody basically it's
not that they're selfish they just they
look out of their own head you can't
help but do that so you just see [ __ ]
from your own perspective like one night
I was doing this gig right down at the
old Boston comedy club in New York City
and one of the acts that was going up
was this was this I think I told this
story before it was it was a comedy team
it says Asian guy and girl and they went
up there and they did this [ __ ] rap
okay and they went up there
and they stuck their teeth out like they
had buck teeth and then they put you
know those glasses that you can put on
those joke ones that make your eyes look
Asian
they had though their Asian and yet they
still put those on and then the other
guy had on a fake gold chain with a
[ __ ] fortune cookie hanging off the
thing so I'm sitting there looking at
before they're going up going oh man
this isn't gonna fly this isn't gonna
fly with this [ __ ] crowd this is
basically what do you call that [ __ ]
what did what was that [ __ ] back in the
day in old-time Hollywood it was almost
like Asian blackface like what they were
doing was [ __ ] was ridiculous I was
thinking that black people watching it
we're gonna be like just all the [ __ ]
that they've been through would look at
and be like what the why they these
[ __ ] why are they selling out their
own [ __ ]
race this is horrific this is [ __ ]
horrific and they didn't that act went
up there and they [ __ ] destroyed and
everybody left their balls off they
thought the fortune cookie thing was
[ __ ] hilarious and I was just like
yeah and people I don't know baby it's
cuz they're [ __ ] on their own race
what the [ __ ] you supposed to do I don't
know I just found that [ __ ] fascinating
so why does that pertain to what the
[ __ ] I just said I don't know this cold
medicines kicking in let me finish this
so anyways this is basically what this
guy does he says just a clarifying buddy
ok now this game started because I hate
watching the news and no matter what I'm
watching SportsCenter usually my wife
will want to change it so naturally
being the [ __ ] that I am I had to
figure out a way to ruin it for so what
I do is turn away from the news whenever
they bring a beginning explaining the
crimes or events of the day based on the
description of the crime or event and
how it was committed or performed I yell
either [ __ ] black guy or crazy-ass
cracker do that she sounds like a fun
[ __ ] game I wouldn't say crazy-ass
cracker I would just say [ __ ] white
dude example news report says when I say
[ __ ] no I wouldn't that's one of the
worst ones ever [ __ ]
it's got no ring it's got no flow that
must have been a bad day with white
people you know usually we're a lot more
creative than that you know named me
after a [ __ ] vegetable is it a
vegetable is it a fruit what the [ __ ] is
it I don't [ __ ] anyways
let's plow ahead example News reporter
says a man was stabbed and I yell out
[ __ ] I know it's a [ __ ] because we
Mexicans can't afford guns and still pay
for our illegal extended family members
we have living with us in our
two-bedroom house if the news report
says a drive-by shooting I yell black
guy come on do I really have to explain
the reason behind that one and of course
if I hear the suspect had body parts of
his victims in the refrigerator
[ __ ] crazy-ass cracker it's because
of this game that my wife has stopped
watching the news altogether and I now
have peace and quiet to enjoy my top
plays of the day fix on SportsCenter
you good for you now see that's
something I don't I don't think that
that's racist because what you don't
have any hatred towards any of those
groups what you're doing is you're
actually you don't want to watch the
news it's [ __ ] depressing you want to
watch sports and then she puts on a
bunch of depressing [ __ ] and what are
you gonna do sit there and get depressed
or you gonna [ __ ] entertain yourself
so you turn it into a [ __ ] game
it's actually a you know I'm not
offended by it I think that's [ __ ]
funny and there's a lot of truth to it
much as I hate to admit some of the [ __ ]
yet we're [ __ ] body parts those scat
videos I don't think I've never seen a
black guy in a scat video not that I
[ __ ] you know watch those things but I
have done the Opie and Anthony show and
occasionally a weird video will come up
ah Jesus I have scar tissue in my brain
from that show a couple of times they
had they brought up one video one time I
I'm not gonna describe it I just refused
to watch it and it still haunts me and I
never even [ __ ] saw it and I'm not
talking about two girls in one cup
because I did see that one but they had
another one where a guy had a jar and he
did something with that jar that you
didn't think was natural he somehow did
it and then the I'm gonna use an
engineering term here the the structure
failed the structure failed the outside
pressure was too much for the structure
and at which point it reached a breaking
point and it failed the jar broke in the
dudes ass okay and I refused to look at
the video and all I heard was everybody
else in the video screaming in horror as
this guy tried to avoid a trip an
embarrassing trip to the emergency room
and clear up the situation himself all
right I'm sorry that's one of those
disgusting things I've ever just
in the podcast let's plow ahead oh
here's a guy responding to they did bad
um
is that racist anyway so yeah Indians
aren't big white people fans because the
British controlled their country for
hundreds of years
see that once again see we all can make
ignorant statements so then you should
hate the English why do you hate all
white people see that we're all just as
dumb oh god damn it this is this is this
is enjoyable alright its plow ahead here
um you know what some English guy said
to me the other day
I was out in Dallas this guy from
Manchester was [ __ ] hilarious
he said to me I was talking about the
[ __ ] Revolutionary War and I wasn't
even trashed in England and when I
brought up the Revolutionary War he goes
oh yeah he goes he goes how's that tax
free country working out for you
ah that was such a [ __ ] good one I
had nothing to say I was like yeah yeah
absolutely [ __ ] right
the rich people [ __ ] stirred up the
morons they kicked the [ __ ] British
out and then the rich people just picked
up with a British left off evidently
alright plowing ahead Indians racist
alright anyways bill so yeah Indians
aren't big white people fans because the
British controlled their country for
hundreds of years even as much as I gave
you [ __ ] I understand that so if you see
me getting off the boat with my [ __ ]
goddamn red hair right you just thinking
I'm another goddamn person coming over
there to [ __ ] over your country I get
that he says the worst part is that it
was a company that ruled them the
British East Indian India Trading
Company pretty much controlled the
country using British soldiers to keep
the Indians in line there was at least
one really bad massacre we're in a
British general had his troops opened
fire on a group of and I don't know how
to say this and I'm not gonna disrespect
these people si
KHS is that Sikhs I have no idea I'm
just okay so I opened up in a fire these
a group of these people just for being
in a group something like 2,000 people
died including many women and children
then Gandhi came and peacefully drove
the Brits out just thought I'd let you
know do
you are just like me you overheard that
[ __ ] are you read about it 20 years that
was the most vague description of a
horrific event I think I've ever read
there was at least one really bad
massacre where a British general had
troops opened fire on a group a group
and like 2,000 people died let me ask
you guys other guys have questioned here
the other people listened to this
podcast when you think of a group of
people at what number do you stop
calling it a group before it becomes a
crowd you know before it just becomes
mass [ __ ] murder I mean I'm for me a
group of people is about seven or eight
you get up to around 15 that's a crowd
mm [ __ ] people are you referring to
that I actually read a little bit about
that about this book on our Winston
Churchill and Gandhi because I wanted to
read about some other history other than
the same [ __ ] stories that they gave
me
it's like church you know I heard all of
Jesus they read Jesus's diary to me for
the first 17 years of my life I got
[ __ ] tired of it I wanted to read
something else so I read yeah there was
a lot worse than that something I
remember reading about this I'm gonna
give you a vague description of what I
remember this is classic from my podcast
cuz nobody knows what the [ __ ] they're
talking about to see this this is how
we're all coming together
yeah the British were [ __ ] over the
Indian people and Indian people did
something they finally [ __ ] snapped
and they went off and they did something
really violent to some of the British
people who were over there including
women and children I believe and they
went say you know we'll say 1 to 10 evil
they went about 5 and then England said
oh yeah we'll [ __ ] show you what
eagle evil is and then they came back
and they went 15 and they were like
[ __ ] burning people alive they just
went around just just shooting everybody
which is what you have to do when you
[ __ ] occupy a country you have to
commit [ __ ] genocide that's the only
way which is why you shouldn't do it you
know
that's why you shouldn't [ __ ] invade
another country because they ain't
[ __ ] leaving they ain't [ __ ]
leaving so I you know what this is like
that's part of a whole other big descrip
discussion I shouldn't even have [ __ ]
brought it up but the only occupation
I've ever seen that ever [ __ ] worked
was in this country any reason why it
worked was because we weren't leaving
and we [ __ ] committed genocide that's
areia and I'm not for that on any
[ __ ] level which is why when I look
around the world and I see certain
people in certain areas I'm not
surprised with what the [ __ ] going
down cuz that's what always goes down so
what always [ __ ] goes down it's
[ __ ] uh I don't know it's [ __ ]
it's evil it's pure [ __ ] evil
um so anyways I YouTube videos of this
week that you know some a lot of that
stuff deserved a lot of justice I'm a
lot more justice than a little under the
weather here YouTube videos of the week
kid dunks himself you know those
douchebags who come out on the court
after the black guys have all [ __ ]
dunked from the foul line and then the
white guys come out with trampolines to
try to roughly duplicate what you just
saw this [ __ ] kid he jumps too high
and he goes through the [ __ ] hoop I
got to give it up to the kid though man
he [ __ ] he didn't go right through
the hoop he was part of the way through
the hoop when he realized that there was
someone coming behind him so rather than
[ __ ] try to go out again he just he
just went right through the hoop was a
very fence up [ __ ] play funny video
oh this one's great funny video making
fun of LeBron commercial with Brett
Favre this [ __ ] guy in this video
doing Brett Favre he not only does he
look like him not only does he sound
like him he even even gets the facial
expressions down of Brett Favre it's
[ __ ] great and I made fun of DJ's
last week so this guy sent me a DJ video
to watch it's called from Kid Koala
skanky panky I get it it takes a lot of
skill but I don't ever want to listen to
it again oh and then somebody a few
about a month ago I talked about drop D
tuning how that was that's how you make
the devil your [ __ ] is you write a song
and drop D tuning
never heard a song that did that that
sounded bad and drop D tuning so he sent
me another video of a great song and
drop D which is a Nirvana negative creep
I guess it's an that I didn't I didn't
[ __ ] look let's get to overrate it
underrated alright
this [ __ ] podcast what the hell's
going on here what are we up to here our
in six minutes Jesus let's wrap this up
let's go real quick here underrated
local bands they're always way more
talented than actually and actually
write and play their own music that
should be heard instead of all the
popular Lady Gaga beyoncé [ __ ] go
out to a bar and enjoy the live music I
agree overrated horoscopes whore-a-scope
s-- why do people think that some
[ __ ] interprets the planets and
starts in stars position is a good flu
influence on their lives you could
literally say whatever you want is a
justification for your actions I'm not a
[ __ ] I'm a Scorpio and Venus is aligned
with the Milky Way no you're a [ __ ]
because you [ __ ] a lot of people alright
stop blaming the heavens you [ __ ]
all the people who freaked out because
they thought their horoscope was
different due to the new 13th sign can
shut the [ __ ] up
if you read further than one paragraph
you discover your sign is different if
you were born when they announced it I
don't know what the [ __ ] that means I
know recently that they somebody tried
to say that every sign was wrong and I
guess people freaked the [ __ ] out oh
here's another racist one god damn I'm
gonna read this next week everybody
chimed in on that topic do you guys have
time to listen to me give somebody some
of my bad advice well of course you do
if you don't just shut the [ __ ] thing
off I'm not holding you hostage um let's
see here bill
oh this guy's says bill loved the
podcast you always answering questions
giving out relationship advice above you
know between men and women so I figured
I'd switch it up here and actually asked
for your advice about a band situation
I'm pretty drunk so I apologize in
advance if my punctuation is incorrect
I joined an established band on bass
about three months ago and spent the
first couple of weeks busting my hump
learning tunes to open for a semi
well-known nation national touring band
since then I burned about three dozen so
I've learned about three dozen songs and
gigged once or twice a week some of them
were high-profile show's opening for
some semi-famous
bands and theaters seating a thousand to
twelve hundred people it's been a good
and steady work but I should have known
that there was a catch
after the fifth gig I finally said do
what the [ __ ] up with the money asked
the bandleader and he said that all the
money goes into a band fund to pay for a
recording of a CD I never agreed to that
when I joined the band so I was like
what the [ __ ]
I asked what happens if I quit the band
before we record the CD and he said all
the money goes to recording whether or
not I'm in on it or not naturally I got
pissed yeah dude what the [ __ ] after a
big balls-out fight he finally offered
to pay me thirty-five bucks per gig
nobody has it harder than musicians
other than [ __ ] strippers or [ __ ]
prostitutes sweatshop labor all right
whatever
it's still a [ __ ] rough gig we
usually get paid between 400 to 600
bucks so I said no I should get paid an
equal one-fifth of whatever the band
makes I'll see you guys get four into
six to six hundred bucks a night yes you
should get like 100 bucks or so right
he's trying to give you 35 I like this
guy standing his ground but this [ __ ]
bird says since I haven't been in the
band as long
I don't deserve an equal share basically
they want to treat me like a hired gun
but don't want to pay me fairly plus I
come to find out the old bass player
quit and a huff with gigs on the books
because they were [ __ ] about [ __ ]
ammo over on money too
I've been a professional reliable I
learned all the [ __ ] songs I showed
up I've been on time and on top all that
there asked me designed posters stickers
a press kit and go out and book more
gigs I feel like I'm being taken
advantage of over here what do I give a
[ __ ] if we record a CD none of these
songs are mine all I have invested in it
is my time it's good steady work and
play pays sorry it's good to get steady
work and play big gigs but we're not
playing too [ __ ] chick music so it's
not like I'm even getting laid out on
the gigs there's always a shortage of
bass players in the world
so I can have a couple other bands I got
a couple other bands nipping at my heels
but none of them are as high-profile you
don't dump your girlfriend so you got
another broad to bang on the side so I
feel like I should keep playing with
these [ __ ] to gain a reputation and
then quit as soon as something better
comes along so what do you think I think
you're absolutely right all right two
things one never go into another
situation unless you've hammered out how
the [ __ ] you're getting paid don't just
be like yeah I'll do it
good you're hired you got immediately
talk about pay because then after four
or five gigs you're already in you're
committed you got time invested and now
they got you by the Bulls so don't do
that again and as far as advice with the
band I would just do exactly what
they're doing they're doing what's best
for them and [ __ ] you so do what's best
for you and [ __ ] them all right if
staying in that band is gonna help you
in the future by being on those high
profile gigs then I'd stay in the band
and when something better comes along
see you right but uh if getting the [ __ ]
out and that some of these bands that
want to [ __ ] play with you actually
seem like they're gonna go somewhere you
know you might want to do that instead
but it's up to you but like I said
choose gogo churches Satan there do
what's good for you don't be a martyr
like that uh like that long haired dude
there all right that's the podcast for
this week thanks to everybody chime in I
apologize if this one was a little bit
scatterbrained I uh I'm really feeling
this [ __ ] goddamn head cold coming on
so that's it have a good week and that's
it
who do you like in the superball wait a
minute this always happens to me always
gonna wrap it up who are you like in the
Superbowl you want a prediction is what
I say take the Steelers and the over all
right because I think in general people
are people are gonna think the Packers
are gonna win you know I haven't watched
any ESPN for some reason I think the
pack people think the Packers are gonna
win whatever the [ __ ] they say is gonna
win bet on the other team and bet the
over because I think that they're gonna
think that it you know because of the
the defenses it's gonna be this you know
Oh school Smash Mouth football type you
don't like this game you know like
football I think that it's gonna
everybody thinks it's gonna be that and
it always goes the other [ __ ] way
so that's it that is the podcast for
this week
good luck to both teams in the Super
Bowl
you know they they'll I was in Dallas
and I actually said some guy went on TV
and said that they were ten thousand
strippers short you know what a sad
state of affairs
ten thousand strippers short game do you
believe people still go to titty bars
unless you're going to one week and
actually get one rubbed out what is the
[ __ ] point you know what I mean then
what'd he do do you go to an ice cream
parlor and have them [ __ ] put ice
cream on a spoon you open your mouth
they put it in your mouth and right as
you go to clamp down they pull it back
out again is that what the [ __ ] you do
overrated titty bars
there's no [ __ ] reason to go to him
you just get frustrated then he get
drunk and then the end this some sort of
fight and then that guy from the Titans
comes in and somebody gets shot and then
he just says I didn't do it and then he
plays for like the Falcons right isn't
that I went down I don't [ __ ] know
all right you know why don't I go [ __ ]
myself so I could head this [ __ ]
guy's
you